good evening it's my pleasure to welcome
our non-gay as alonso back to hastings
all as this terms
Eero Saarinen visiting professor the
siren and professorship was established
in 1984 through the generosity and
efforts of the architect Kevin Roche to
honor his mentor
Eero Saarinen who received a bee arch
degree from Yale in 1934 this endowed
chair enables the school to invite a
distinguished architect to teach a
design studio each term previous siren
and visitor visiting professors include
Richard Rogers Denise Scott Brown and
Robert venturi Phillip Johnson with
Peter Eisenman Cesar Pelli zaha hadid
and Frank Gehry in spring 2014 the chair
was held by the Toronto based architect
Brigitte chim and this past term the
team called fat sang their collective
swan song while sharing the siren and
chair Anandi's Diaz Alonso was born in
Argentina where he began his
professional training at the National
University of Rosario before working in
the office of Marius title Irabu in
Barcelona and then coming to New York to
receive advanced architectural
professional training at Columbia after
graduating from Columbia in 1999 and a
years senior designer in Peter
Eisenman's office
professor Diaz Alonzo founded the faro
tech architects as a multidisciplinary
practice operating on the cutting edge
of digitally determined architecture in
2005 he was the winner of the MoMA ps1
young architects program and in 2012 we
received the educator of the Year award
from the American Institute of
Architects going on in 2013 to win the a
R&D award for emerging architecture and
a progressive architecture award for his
design of the teason born of me
a pavilion museum in Patagonia Argentina
ern ingenious Alonso is one of the
leading talents working in the field of
digital design with an original approach
that transcends the algorithm algorithm
ik repetitions of so many to engage in a
dazzling world of color and narrative
his design architectural designs have
been featured in exhibitions at the
venice architecture Biennale the London
architecture Biennale in the Archie lab
in Oriels France as well as displayed in
featured exhibitions in reading
architectural museums such as the New
York MoMA SF MoMA Art Institute of
Chicago in the Mack Center in Vienna the
firm's work is also part of the
permanent collection of the frac center
of SFM MoMA SF MoMA and New York MoMA
the T Sanborn amis a collection and Mac
and the Art Institute of Chicago
professor Diaz Alonso is an inspiring
and dedicated educator he holds an
ongoing appointment as architectural
design professor in the urban strategies
postgraduate program at the University
apply of Applied Arts in Vienna which he
will have to give up in the fall when he
becomes the distinguished professor and
graduate programs chair at the Southern
California Institute of architecture
better known as sci-arc where he will
resume responsibilities before basically
running the school PA professor Diaz
Alonso is no stranger to Yale in 2010 10
he was Lewis icon visiting assistant
professor please join me in welcoming
Hernandez Alonso back to Yale back to
this room and and for honoring James
Bond's and admonition and Yale tradition
by titling his lecture tonight shaken
not stirred
Bob thank you I cannot thank you enough
for so many kind words an invitation
over the years so let me get going
I want to do a little it's most fun no
the tour on the title so to be
absolutely honest to be absolutely
honest Jake in Noster I was not really
thinking that the first one the first of
this lecture and this title for this
year will be here it was Richard the
familiy who said oh such a great title
in honor or dignity and I want to say
for the record I don't think that Bob is
neither shaken or stirred I want to be
very clear about that they have nothing
to do with that have to do with
tradition the martinis and so on but I
really want to say I want a really thank
Bob for all this year it's not very
usual these days anymore to have these
where the generosity and the curiosity
to support young faculty or people who
come from completely different approach
you understand of architecture and
sometimes we take those things for
granted and trust me on this is not that
often so he has been a very generous
person and support in my life and I will
keep looking for advice in the years to
come as I became a dinosaur in September
which I need your help but I'd also I
will be the CEO which is so East Coast
and so yeah which is so unlike shark but
anyway that's a different footnote so
the title of the lecture shaking aster
has to do with a notion which I think
many of many of us and particular people
in my generation who were brought into
the way when already the computational
architecture was in full flesh but also
the same time in which the
ocean of theory in this course was built
a visit and revaluated so let me run it
clip basically what I'm trying to say is
this for the gentlemen vodka martini
shaken not stirred
Touche a martini shaken not stirred
would you get me a medium dry vodka
martini why shaken not stirred shaken
not stirred vodka martini shaken monster
shaken not stirred
Lokomotiv chicken stood give it him so
as you can see as years go by and the
modern bond come to play he's too busy
doing stuff killing people having sex
with women all the wonderful things that
Shane's balls do to be wasting time in
those little details jokes aside I
really think it's it's not it's an
important statement for me in the sense
of in many many ways it took it has took
me a long time to figure it out where
the nature of the work is and I really
felt like I never completely fall and
any of the categories and even in this
current times which some of my dears
colleagues and friends are very
discussing and embracing like orient the
object ontology or any other things I
never felt like any necessity to do that
I always been much more interested in
the production of any score that is
embedded in the doing much more in the
way that I don't know like film or
fashion or any other disciplines will do
so that's basically my stake the whole
thing I was shaking this term is just
give me the drink
so whatever what I want to touch what I
want I want to cover many things today
but basically at the end of the day it
can be reduced to three maybe three main
points one you have to do which I think
in many many ways for those of us could
be really interesting in the formal
project in the form processing the form
forms form that only the four in many
ways and shape and and directions
I think the clothes really has been
always a part of the argument a part of
discussion and I have to say that my own
work I will say trace way more on the
pronoun velocity that the notion of
close reading but I will say the two
main things that drive the world and we
produce in the office which of course
has been informed from my many years of
teaching in Syria Canon yell in other
places we had to do which for me is the
biggest contribution contribution that
digital tools and computational brought
to the table which is a possibility of
new coherences
what I mean by that is if you think for
example in the beginning of 19th century
in German rationalism and Romanticism
those idea that can coexist were almost
it was impossible now computers allows
us for example to be ultra rational
machines algorithm on that and to be
subject or open to the idea to be
contaminating to start to negotiate and
produce new coherences and I will
elaborate that later on did so the
second parties were called agents of
contamination I think we are and I was
talking this we were discussing this
with mortgage and hisses till this
morning in many ways one could argue
that we are in kind of a succession
digital period like the secession
movement was this formal resistance in
which they are the artists and artists
were trying to reclaim a sense of
individual notion with in the middle of
Industrial Revolution and I would argue
that the notion of wages and
contamination are different mechanism
that many of us are we trying to figure
it out how to reclaim that sense of that
within the larger context of the problem
we're trying to work I'm not going to
read any of this you can choose to read
it or not there's certain kind of
certain basic points about this notion
so the notion of velocity as I said is
not it's not for everybody it's not
anything to require but it's something
that fascinates me and I intend to be
obsessed with that and I will always
able make a relation between obsession
and velocity I don't think every
obsession requires a velocity but in my
case I think or obsessively amble to
obsession and velocity there go hand to
hand and the other thing which I will
say is in many ways some of the world
and it has been associated with these
conditions have to no be as you do with
the work of process research
experimentation transformations
no no then I think really interests me
or apply in terms of my world and much
more interesting the notion of hyper
reality when interesting is that the
work is who is a word that is built to
be real even though the real is no maybe
with the absolute of the conventional
real we have to do maybe with a
construction and parallel reality so I
don't consider my work research I didn't
consider my work experimental I don't
consider my work visionary even though
it may be perceived like God I just try
to give an answer to a problem and
exposed to me in the way that any other
that will do I'm aware that what I do
looks in the way that it looks oh I
understand the process from that but I
do not pray like that and in that sense
I'm a very conventional architects no no
one project we done in the office no one
project I'll show you tonight is an a
self-made invented problem all of them
has been a competition or a client on
exhibition or something was commissioned
to us to me this is an important thing
because he has to do with the Beirut of
my original my original education in
Argentina so we are I think in an era
still we are in shifting paradigms in
the way that our field has been shake in
the last 25 years or so and I think the
the the amazing exhibition here some of
the early stages of that not so early
actually I think that was already in the
second phase deal with that but I will
say window shifted parallels which I
think there are many there couple of end
are more important than others to me one
is what I would call the shift from
representation to simulation which to me
is a critical one I like to think that
my work belong to the tradition of those
architects in which the relation of
representation and relation of the
production of the thing were very
intertwined I mean from people like Rick
Malaysia who have work or extra metric
or more forces in their elaborate
drawings or Peter with all this
analytical work so to me those always
been in which the notion representation
is part of the speculation now my entry
has to do more how the simulation became
a shifting paradigms I don't think the
simulation eliminates representation I
think observe representation and add
other layers to it and so they work
literally try to deal a lot with that
and I think part of you have to do my
own obsessions well originally I wanted
to be a filmmaker and not an architect
and I think you have to do they do the
ambition to integrate that but at the
same time it has to do with a very
brutal honest way to work we have to do
that we are using animation software and
we using camera driven and built on
camera might as well start to use
those occasions as an opportunity to
rethink how we design and how we work
and this is animation one of the last
competitions and we did this for Museum
Budapest and part of the notion is the
way that we were trying to design some
of its projects we try to build these
films first and how the project will be
in relation to the camera so in the way
that we will operate traditionally with
plants or sections we try to do the same
using this visual cameras and so on also
we add in a whole series of layers of
thing that don't really exist it's not
like a building will be barreling or
they would be moving those are part of
the construction of the cinematic
effects or whether the film tried to do
that then the project's tried to capture
some of those senses but it's not like
it's not like it's not like it's a
building with robotic parts and they
will move on so on these will have to do
much more with the process of the
developing the methodology to work on
the exact the other thing which I think
is important relation to this is unlike
some of the work has been done and it's
done through it we use multiple platform
and I believe a lot in the notion of
corruption so softwares and how we work
multiple of them I'm not married to any
particular a dose of dogma or software
we do we use sometimes a script and
parametric effect sometime we use paint
brush Maya whatever it is so we don't so
I don't subscribe to one particular
religious approach the original software
I'm when I'm interested in terms of the
technology it had to do this pensions
and the murder and imagined quality of
the emerging qualities of new aesthetics
then we can produce a relation to that
now I will be the first one to say yes
I'm a formalist I'm a proud one
I never hide I think we should have a
parade now that the country is evolving
in a set in other forms of life I think
it's time for us a formalist to come out
into the open and don't be ashamed or
being but also I think you have to do if
you're interested of of course the
notion of geometry is crucial in a hole
in the hole in the whole establishment
but I would argue that my only interest
in terms of part of a part of the
by the worgen part of this development
and this tool have to do with another
shifting paradigm which I will consider
the notion of geometry to image what I
mean by that is we are mediated by this
images even what we do in drawings there
are images of drawings and this may be
completely oversimplification of it but
they really believe it drawing it's only
drawn if you do it by hand if you do
what the computer is an images are not
drawn and it's a whole different other
ethical apparatus to it attached to it
so I'm very much interested in the
condition of image at the vehicle for
the production form or cinematic for me
if you will which is I think ok so but
that doesn't mean we will not do a plan
for the project when I'm meeting my dad
is not the geometry but not gonna be in
the traditional sense it's reinforced
but they have to do with the relation of
how they image opera in relation to that
is not that different to thing let's say
the difference between x-ray and an MRI
so it's not like the MRI doesn't have
similar information that right it just
come very different way and it produces
a whole series and multiplicities in
relation to it then I think allows to
have like if holistic or kind of a
overall understanding another thing the
other element which is crucial in my
obsession have to do with the notion of
another what I would consider shifting
paradigm which is the notion of beauty -
beautiful
and this doesn't quite work in English
assume in the language that you listen
is English which can be discussed but it
was much better in Spanish in Spanish
the difference between Vanessa and
Benito
what I mean by that is beauty it's kind
of a Canon establish it's established
over time by cultural society but the
understanding of principles of it Bonito
in Spanish is more the temporal thing
it's something they have to do with the
immediacy of that time of the moment so
there are certain things that it will
change what we consider bonito today
will not be 10 years from now so
beautiful is not exactly that I know the
English be building beautiful are more
similar but that's what I'm trying to
convey so when I am interested is kind
of a much more contemporary merging
qualities of beauty which are belong to
a particular period of time
and is not the rule of global by the
traditional sense of the classical sense
or even the scholar sense of what we
consider beauty
so now working into into the work of the
project in the into the projects I will
say the word and we produce in the last
10 or 12 years in the office can be
divided basically in a genus of
contamination I think there has been
five phases one biology ornament cinema
rito-san butchery what I mean by biology
have to do with which many of ya get it
out okay
we're ready to go okay so I have to do
which I think as I was discussing this
morning with some other students in the
90s there was a necessity to produce a
quasi scientific element as an alibi
there was a need with all the computer
computer and software technology will
imagine in our in our field
there was another like to try to make we
were borrowing elements and one of them
was a quest isn't difficult biological
one and so on of course there was a
direct close sympathy between the formal
behavior of the thing how that bull be
biological and so on so in a way when we
like it or not I would I would have said
that the early part of the world was
related to that problem and have to do
with the lack of challenge on my part of
the lack of forcing the subject on
contamination to the nature where the
tool was given you in a way the early
work was very much driven by the
capacity of what the surfer was able to
do so and another time I will say it was
kind of a very kind of hyper coherency
so there was this idea that it was
singular surface trying to design
there's a lot of topological variations
and so on but one of the processes I
show he introduced the possibility which
it was somebody was commenting on the
work of the condition of the growth of
grotesque certain grotesque quality and
to me that was a very interesting notion
because there was kind of an intuition
that there was an emerging aesthetic
effect that was coming from
generated by computer but nobody was
really writing about it or really
speculating about that they still was a
kind of a technical approach to some of
the arguments and the the perception of
the grotesque was an interesting one
because in a way the first assumption
and one does and I did like everybody
else is the grotesque isms in disgust
you know or ugly or something like that
it's not the origin of the word
grotesque have to do and we can trace it
to let's say some some of the black
period paintings of Goya it's basically
one any aesthetic effects or aesthetic
condition cannot be catalog or put in
place in relation to the Canon establish
of aesthetic moment so to me that was an
interesting one because it was a way to
start to liberate that some of the some
of those rules now the problem is one of
the promises that the grotesque he can
be coordinate to a pointer can be
manipulated to a point but I think it's
more like an emerging quality so it is
very difficult to break it down in some
kind of a methodological or a polite way
of working which in a strange strange
way I'm very fascinated by it so when we
were doing the the the competition for
ps1 that no she was very much in place
so we start to flirt also with the
notion of horrific and narrative of a
ryokan cinematic narrative like alien or
Venus code and so on so part of the data
revision that you were seeing was
basically the way that we present the
project to the jury we didn't reveal the
drawings of the model and the billion we
have then that that movie goes for like
20 minutes so the idea was to immerse
them in this kind of narrative in which
you don't know exactly what you're
looking so we were borrowing for this
terrific constructions which is
something that you can manipulate in
particular moment to create a sense in
the others and so on now the problem
with these things is then once in a
while in my case very much once in a
while you win one of these things and
then you have to build it and and this
is the moment and you think look
minimalism may have some merits that
these need to be that you need to be
revisited
but then is too late and you are in it
and so then scripting is not just about
the process formal it's a way to start
to manufacture close to 1500 piece of
structure in which not two of them were
equal which is a terrible idea
the thing which I always said to the
students every time if you want to
present a competition it's really really
important that your engineer has a
British accent he goes a long way to
convince the jury that the thing will
not fall apart
German accent is the second choice try
to stay away from Midwest accents
engineers they don't come find a lot of
security in the jury anyway we did it we
built it it was very walls but it has a
whole series of interesting things that
they were emerging which was some of the
material effects and we were doing we
were pushing because the time frame was
too short so fibreglass I started to
bubble a band so a bunch of things that
happened by accident then Nicola you
know software at the time was the new
sign critic was telling me pattern and
you did that on purpose because you're
so into the horrific and so on and the
answer was of course it wasn't
but then that things start to trigger
and I'm very very I mean very strong
believer in the mechanism up top see of
working the decisions in a literary
stall for work you win and Rick when you
work with when you work with somebody
with an rego lagoon you or somebody with
Peter Eisenman the desert you have to be
paying attention because every money you
can learn something that you can steal
and put in your pocket and take it away
for the rest of your life I think a
stealing is the best form of learning
metaphorical and literally so you can
steal things along the way in the office
is good too but what happened with that
was whether learning from foreign Rick
was the notion about Topsy which is the
idea that you do a project and then the
Gerasenes approach ago some mistakes or
some things or some byproducts of that
project coming and the genesis of the
next one so in doing that kind of
acceleration distortion permanent state
of transformations of the material
Hammond P is one it start to trick an
interesting idea to splurt the national
species or blood coagulation so what if
instead to start the thing in Francis
type we start to thinking in terms of
species and and the process start to
begin by families instead to work in a
singular personal time we will work of
cellular cellular
cell system someone we did this solo
show and they said mama we convinced and
then we didn't want to do like a
conventional show Shirley moons and Troy
but we wanted to show more like an
effect or a process in permanent state
of transformation so you when you will
wake you when you will walk in you will
see all the cells and then you will see
all the animation that make these cells
and to become in the concert hall or of
course it's a huge level of fakeness and
mutation and design which I'm very
sympathetic to it so it's never so
linear that's why for example parameter
C's and all those things are not so
appealing to me but the idea was again
to start to operate with the National
Association so you can have a whole
families of process that emanate about
singular entities and in that sense
that's what I think to have a certain
method ecologic is an important one but
it's not so much I think about how do
you know which one goes which I don't go
you start to see them as a continues
that keep transforming from one project
to another so when they show move from
one museum to the other one and so on
and this isn't 2006 but then uribe see
some of those ideas maybe seven years
later we were working for Boeing for
almost two years
and trying to develop a Center for
aerospace experience the idea was to
produce a customer experience center for
the CEO of big company so in a way they
were not so interested in some of our
recent world and I'm sure I will show in
a bit but they were interesting to go
back to some of those kind of a more
pure it small surfaces and so on which
we were we were would then unfortunately
the project right now is a limbo and the
person who was working with us inside
the company got promoted and and the
project got demoted so which is a
interesting in any way to tell the truth
the project was getting it's a long
story but in any case we are grateful to
them they allows us to learn a bunch of
things and anyway they're actually
they're terrific line to work with but
sometimes those big corporations is very
difficult to get everybody on the same
page and the right time in any case but
my point is the ideas are never really
some statics you like I like to think
that you call ways
what happens is when you're confronted
with certain project or certain
limitations you go back and revisit some
of them so some of the ideas and you
work you know you never know what
they're gonna come to play so for me
that's what I'm saying
to organize the notion of a species so
even though this project was 2013 I
belong to a new species of contamination
that was more in 2005 2004 whatever so
it's not the best thing that we ever
done but it was okay but the other thing
was really interested in was in which
they're creatures one part of problem
half half of the project was also to
work in all the media with Alex McDowell
the ordinary Hollywood stage designer
and production designer it was about not
only Turkey checked or all the other
things that would happen in parallel to
it it has a huge amount of technology
that will be embedded so the idea is if
the people for Qantas can the whole
thing will change to red and need the
people from British Airways will be
black and white so there would be a
whole series of things so part of what
part of the fascination of the project
was not chase the pure fun aspect it was
have to do also with a whole series of
international media now another agent of
contamination over time has been for
example ornament which is something that
again to me was one of the pre
interesting things that computers
brought back to the table the idea that
you can have a coherency that includes
onami which again modernism many others
started with other flaws others were
very capable of bearing edge in killing
so we were not interested and not
interesting per se the traditional sense
of honoring what I think is interesting
is then what I would call it if I have
to do more with plastic surgery like or
nominee one way you can think it's
accessorizing
putting a bunch of jewels on yourself
this is more like plastic surgery so
it's like the how ornament is start to
become embedded with the whole nature of
the origin of the project so for example
if you look at when we were doing ps1
ps1 was based on one cell the producing
huge amount of variation but the policy
betrayus always to the same one when we
start to do as the project is going the
the project the big project capital
project the office project we start to
work with multiple cells and the idea is
that these multiple cells can produce
these multiple ontology so the project
it would have a certain level of
variation we build with that so some of
those cells can be embedded with certain
structural properties and I would
envelope like unlike previous one
this word is made out of five different
it doesn't look like but it was made out
of five components that can be repeated
and produced variation this was a an
invited competition for a guest house or
artist president in Paris for their
collect or not ELISA Lucy but the other
thing which also this one trigger was to
rediscover my my love and passion for
for to speculate about drawings and
assemblies and so on so the idea how we
really how how would really relate with
the notion of drawings as images and not
drawing such a hand contraction by
compass and three angles I had to say I
never sketch even when I was working by
hand I always used to work with compass
and triangles always been obsessed with
super precise way of contracting which
also that's why I think I like so much
computers the level of precision of it
the other shifting paradigms and I think
have to do with some of these ideas and
it's very pressing the work is the idea
of moving to zoom in and zoom out in
front of a scale well one other thing
which it's kind of problematic at by the
same time I think it's a wonderful
opportunity working in with some of
these toys have to do with the notion
that it doesn't quite require
predetermine a scale by but what I mean
by that is when I used to draw by hand I
mean you will have the balloon and you
have to decide in advance I'm gonna do a
one five one two five hundred one 200
one 100 drawing I mean you will have to
do it before because if not it will not
go anywhere
so you were forced already to produce
the next amount of information and
usually the way that you work you will
be scaling up as the days go by so my
progeny school intro sorry will be you
will start with one to five hundred plan
try
put in the side or lay them inside then
the next part the next drawing would be
one to two hundred plan eventually you
will make it to 100 150 construction
later 125 and you were really good at
ready you will go to 110 but it was a
kind of a progressive thing now with the
computer all that can can collapse into
one entity potentially so it has a sense
of in which the scale is really in a way
the scale is pretty much related to a
man of kind of formal effects of desire
or other things so the scale can have to
come to play in a different way that
just the absolute terms every wall so
this was a solo show that we didn't Adam
at in Vienna in which I like him ps1 we
wanted to work with much more literal
physical manifestation of cinematic
effects so the idea was not so much to
produce a singular object pretending to
be an architecture quasi building a ps1
but to really work with kind of a much
more art object scale in which the
collection of all of them would organize
the space in a different way so it was a
way to try to blur the building between
a blur or create a bridge between an
architecture way of thinking the Spy's
but to my best effort every time I try
to flare with art it doesn't quite work
because if you train with an are Getti
you're gonna you're trained like an
architect you would think like an
architect so I all say this approach you
have artistic effects but I will not
consider project of art the way this
assembly the whether you think about the
space and so on you have to do much more
with ejector logic but my desire was
also to work with it with this problem
of the scale and to try to produce like
a certain protocol --'tis that can be
scale up into other projects so as you
can maybe notice by now the modus
operandi so the office is very much we
don't leave anything out so every face
you have more stuff so with it ornament
yes now we're going to do something else
but ornament doesn't always stays so
it's not about replacing one agency of
contamination another is keep adding to
the pool so again it's have to do with
this notion of evolving the species or
whatever we want to call it so this
notion of unit of formal units ourselves
we're going to call
again as we move up we move by it again
more and more complex so we were
developing these benches for the woman
that we were in the house so out of that
variation of that it became the chair
that was commissioned it to us by the
Art Institute which was basically
literally playing around today's with a
scripting that will produce a beautiful
bodice of distortion in the famous inch
chair we literally model the Eames chair
and we start to use a whole series of
biros to distort and so on they have to
do also with my obsessions they have to
do by with medicine and very bad things
so I mean the more I I always think that
working by a position is an interesting
one so if you're interested in beautiful
Beauty the more disgusting thing that
you can think of other things that the
most is cut anything and you can pay
attention to the better chance that
there is in that confidence some new
possibilities would emerge but at the
same time I am as I said I'm very
obsessed with the notion of atrocity and
how to control those mechanisms so the
work is really about working on and keep
working on it and so on and is never so
much about making a singular decision
it's all about to keep the that kind of
a permanent valuation of multiple if
possible to work in multiple scale at
the same time I always try in the office
to try to work in different scales in
different processes in time because when
I work with a singular project I tend to
be a disaster because I have tried to
put everything in one which is still do
but when you have more projects like you
is like having multiple kids you can
spread your love or hate whatever it is
that so the other edge of the
contamination call is the notion of
misfits or occult rituals I start to pay
a lot of tension the notion of rituals
because it's something really most of
the not all of them but most of them
have this fascinating quality to have
something very sophisticated and
something very primitive coexisting one
of them and I'll get back to that but
this was the first the first thing that
we were with Alessi and it was a silver
work collection now we call him meat and
manners in was in 2009 and part of that
was to look at that but
to me this one was really almost a
stylist it was basically the thing
completely behaved like a regular
silverware it just look we're and fancy
but it doesn't change anything so there
was something about that that it was not
ritualistic enough
nevertheless in these multiple families
they were saying in Parliament with
Alessi Selfridges in London commissioned
us to have some kind of installation in
one of those their windows which at the
end didn't happen but and in parallel to
that we were doing a competition for a
media Museum in San Sebastian was called
Tower colada because it was in an old
tobacco factory so this notion of the
scale is assume even zoom out to me is
one of the most interesting
possibilities that working in this way
allows us so the idea that what it was
in the Mac an object which they can
became a silverware or an art piece for
a department store in London can also
have a similar genetic code for the lack
of better world to produce a competition
for a museum so they don't so how you
start to low the scale becames
I would not say arbitrary but it has to
start to became a specific interest how
you want to move the effect from one to
the other one the other thing which was
interesting about this particular
project was it was a president it was an
an intervention and renovation of a
factory so there was something really
fascinating to me was the first project
that we done in a long time probably
since never in which you need to coexist
with an existing tissue which was a
really interesting idea this notion of
friction between the species of the city
as an existing quality and what we can
add to it so that again the up top see
this logic of the autopsy that were you
work in that they became it Genesis that
can generate metaphor the next one this
notion of working with an existing
tissue it trigger a curiosity my part
what if some of the world and we've been
doing a start to negotiate to observe
and incorporate familiarity to produce
conditions that we can
nice in this cave was an existing
building but what if we start to
fabricate some of them what if we start
to relay with platonic geometries or
grid or things that we can relate to it
in a different dimension like maybe by
confrontation by friction either way
particularly the plans drawing was the
one that trigger that the most in India
so I mind is a very playful and curious
one so usually war by by intrigues or
thing that triggers so in a way Houston
this morning I tried to be very honest
lecture so everything I'm telling you
right now is absolutely honest but
doesn't mean I'm telling you the truth
what I mean by that is unconstructed
right now a narrative or a way to think
about the work which I'm not quite sure
that I was exactly what I was thinking
when we were doing because as I said is
the Daniel Craig days one thing it's
much more a much more interesting in the
doing of the production of the things
that they have like a predefined
speculation in advance now I think you
build that in any way and you start to
became something that he became fellow
tamati it's like riding a bicycle or
anything else that you do and then you
realize that actually there is a lot of
mental to madness or whatever whatever
one of those cliches we can call it so
to me like for example this was one of
the first person we incorporate platonic
geometry one of the very few first one
then we have that you can recognize
circles there which we never did before
it was kind of a super intentional
attitude to have no recognizable
platonic geometry in the work so for me
in the national rituals and this bring
us to the the the last 25 minutes of the
lecture I'm thinking half way right and
we okay how many of you are fall asleep
alright so which is really the core of
the work which is the most recent work
which is the notion of retos and for
example where I was talking our
romanticism and rationalism of the
National retos idea that you have the
matador with some of the most elaborate
assume that not even women would use and
then he's doing the most brutal thing
which is killing this guy right so there
is something about the the fascinates me
which we use it a lot when we did our
second or third collection for LSA which
which is along the same lines I'm gonna
cut this animation short because it's
this way too long but basically both of
them one is 2010 the other one is 2011
but the one particularly one in the left
was both predicate in the notion again
to this kind of a high n low and so part
of the thing is and this was for Alessi
ofagina
which is the cannabis the high-end
collection of them which is it's
fabricated and the premise that people
are not gonna really use it so you don't
need to worry about that much about that
part you have to look that you can use
it and if you decide to it you can use
it but you're not obligated so part of
what I wanted to do I was watching crow
number three other time and they bring
their son what I wanted to do was a
series of object that you will be very
afraid of using and that you will feel
uncomfortable you have to use it so so
that's what moral is where we go but
again it goes for like 20 minutes
because it was almost like a commercial
that we did for them but basically in
the first collection it was this one
which was completed on imagine our
number table and my favorite piece is
the silverware but it was really
interesting because if you will eat you
will have to eat like this so will
completely change the way that you
behave to the person next to you so this
is for those who think that it's team
formalism doesn't create social behavior
he does it just doesn't do the proper
one but to me this was a this became
like a fantastic petri dish of a whole
series of ideas and if he became
something else oh but the bad idea to
produce a whole series of objects and a
collection it was all based on the same
series of formal configurations and come
as many as we can came from trays to
silverware to us try to
got cars now they had the collection one
year later was a slightly difference we
would we were trying much more to work
with them with a means of production so
the idea to figure that out a single
sheet of metal which is really what they
prefer so we start to figure it out okay
what if we work with a single sheet of
metal
manipulated and embedded with ornament
and then we can have the candles and the
candle wax will be part of it so it was
part much more the real cool thing you
start to play so because idea will be
that the wax will get into the things
and it will became much more dirty and
so on so at the end this is the one he's
going to production it's a wine it's too
small we did also a display system for
them and that was in parallel when we
were at Peter nowhere asked me this is
2011 or 2012 sorry when they Marquis
apartments by Schindler got reopened
three years ago in Los Angeles he asked
a couple of architects and couple of
artists to do series of small
intelligence in four of the garages and
the budget was very very tight but I was
really flirting with this notion of
Romanticism and mutation and growth and
decay and all these agencies I'm talking
about the rituals the retail of
cemeteries and dying and particular
Mexican cemeteries and Mexican funerals
which is very close to Argentina they're
even more tragic there Santino was there
more dark so what we decide was with a
little budget and we have we went to the
flower market in Los Angeles and I hired
three ladies who make funeral
arrangements and they had this technique
that they can make a structure of the
flowers so we did this and we bought off
the shape of the shell a couple of thing
we put a bunch of DVD players inside
with animations they show supposed to be
dinner for three months in the summer by
the first months it smell like a
cemetery the flowers start to get dry
and eventually everything collapse but
again something that was kind of a game
on almost like a flirtation as I said
with this arctic artistic quality it
became like potentially something really
interesting methodical which is I always
been very bad with color and figure out
how to use
and I thought okay we start to
incorporate flowers and vegetation and
all those things and it may be way to
deal with color so we did a whole series
of this is a story but we did a whole
series of moves on flowers and we will
transform the colors and so on but so
part of that thing which again was in a
small art installation became the
trigger to develop a whole a whole
ageneral and relation to that so by now
we have a species cells ornament flowers
and romantic ornaments and whatever so
Francesca won't help or who has this
amazing foundation in museum Vienna
called thyssen-bornemisza r21 which is
basically cause her contemporary
collection commissioned and three
architects to develop small pavilions
museums in different parts of the world
we commissioned this one in Patagonia so
the idea was to produce this
over-the-top ornamental structure than
in which we don't build the volumes of
the space the still structure will be
there but that we can grow all the
flowers and vegetation so it can change
over time so and view during the season
of the year the building will look
different who have different colors will
have different effects and effects and
all that it was too big have a whole
series of issues but the idea but it was
basically park with some pavilions along
the way this was a model than we did for
for the Venice Biennale
so four years later we get commissioned
by the regional agency of Barcelona we
are working this project if this will
not a--not be assuring being recorded
let's say the political climate in May
elections will depend some will decide
it is project build or not that's as far
as I'll go
but we got commissioned this pedestrian
bridge in San I'd really be sauce which
is a city next to Barcelona which
connects with the personal forum is to
senator the vessels in a way the project
is for year later but we went back and
we revisit some of those ideas then we
were developing for Tizen born Ibiza so
in this project where we work
right now still work in progress and we
when working with close boninger the
general engineer who's work with wolf
Briggs and Sahadi and actually he keeps
thinking he keep telling us that our
acted to tall structures super
conservative because he said we have way
too many columns I think he spent too
much time working with wolf who doesn't
want to have any columns
I like columns I like to have a lot as
far I can have a lot of sums in it's
fine
so so the idea one column doesn't appeal
to me I like a lot of things so but I
thought what I like about the idea of a
lot of column was a way to organize the
kind of Italian of the structure to
became the formal thing but also the
idea that bridge can have some
flexibility because this is for people
to walk run and bicycle that's it
there's nothing else there's no cars and
so on so it doesn't need to have it
doesn't lead to support a heavy load
though it's a fairly light one so we
were looking a lot into bamboo bridges
and things like that so part of the
principles like that and it doesn't look
like but this actually is it's basically
there are only three modules that get
repeat and rotate and it's really bridge
only in this part in this part is more
like a pathway this is an ecological
protected area it doesn't look as good
as that in green is actually much more
dry and so on but part of the challenge
is this is at the edge of the river when
it connects with the Mediterranean Sea
so part of the problem has to do with
corrosion and so on so some moment we
were thinking to do everything in bamboo
but then we realized if I'm boost super
expensive to do like so now we're going
with this but anyway this is the latest
version the problem will be others
coming up but this is what it is
so the for those of you who've been in
Barcelona itoki forest somewhere here
this is somewhere here so these are the
end so you will connect their work thing
and they will connect you with but this
is what I was talking about this
basically this one main module and gate
produces many variations or rotations
and so on he works basically like a
jewelry chain so we have certain
flexibility
and then we have all these kind of eyes
and fears and we can have weird strange
plants they're part of this ecological
thing anyway okay the drawings are super
heavy I don't know why that's my main
elevation some of the details and all
the rotations of the angles of the piece
how you combine and assembly and all
that so right now we're getting
terrified because the we presented to
the mayor of San Andreas and the mayor
Barcelona and the neighbors like it and
so on so we don't have a much OPC
opposition left so if it doesn't happen
we have to political climate or because
we cannot push forward
they also commissioned us to do a
proposal for the sidewalk the bridges
here so the Commission has also to work
in the sidewalk for San Andreas house
this is one a few times and collaborate
with my wife Florencia Peter because as
I said I cannot I don't know what to do
with colors and she saw that I'm working
with color so she develop all this
ceramic pattern which we make it darker
and more sinister it's way more happier
but I couldn't take it in the renders so
we went from the Prince of Darkness
style to it but it's basically shy
walking basically to control the sand
and but the idea was to produce almost
this kind of again almost this cinematic
effect so there's a lot of similarities
of things but the idea is also to
produce the Berek continuum in space
so of course we look a lot of moola
marks sidewalk in Rio some of and wreak
operations in Park and and a bunch of
other things but this one
the other ones nowhere
we'll see what happens but so the last
part the last 50 minutes is about the
most recent work and the one I'm
obsessed the most we have to do with
butchery which is one of what I call the
new coherences butchery Kant who my
interest in a very strange as the last
Asian contamination to that in a very
strange way this is Frances mom on one
of the most famous chef in Argentina we
decide six years ago since then he want
to start to combine some of the most
primitive way of cooking a whole cow the
way they go just did it but he start to
develop all the structures for us and so
on and then combine him with some of the
most sophisticated high grossing cooking
so that was really interesting to me but
also there was some a little bit of
biographical thing about being
Argentinean and a spaniel from my
father's side and we come in father and
something very weird that I became a
became very obsessed with this notion of
very Argentinean motives and so on and
go back to in a primitive way and figure
it out how the filter technology can
produce this kind of anomaly so I'm not
talking about the makers I'm not talking
about their and really literally talking
about butchery and there is incredible
sophistication for many we are one have
to do the real thing and someone but the
other one is fascinating one is is one
of the first thing there is really three
dimensional cut it's really
topologically the interaction between
the act of a geometrical cut but also
the relation of the resistant of the
flesh the bounds each of them produce
something else oh it's incredible it is
incredi precise and it's to the service
of something incredibly primitive so
three out of three
it got me at hello so so oops
okay this one is not playing but in any
case we went full flesh into it and this
one was the first one after that is the
second version for teasing the
thyssen-bornemisza pavilion and we may
be when wait to literal the animation is
even worse actually it's better than
maybe naeun play out is some there are
some vegetarians in the audience but
there was something about this kind of
the dirtiness almost start to produce a
much more surreal again keep in mind
that the cinematic the production of the
image is very much in play so then
working through a series of chairs and
benches and we did with similar
principles so we start to look into the
things but also the detachment of the
structure from the skin in very much
using butchery techniques so to do the
chair and to do this bench but there was
there is a whole repertoire they come
for that and you follow it actually it's
as precise to see to follow any kind of
the scripted geometry course but
actually give you a lot of insight about
how to manipulate and operate in the
three-dimensional environment so of
course there is a kind of an exotic and
shock effect of working with butchery
and cows and all that but there was an
incredibly precise way to do the things
so that's always what that always would
interest me between these objects of
obsessions whether I call it I mean this
idea of agencies of contamination and
allow you to do that so in parallel to
that we were commissioned to do a
chandelier for really much in France
again this was and also I was really
looking into the notion of certain
literality I think many of the world and
we done in the past we were flirting
with all the things we're always we were
working to process of attractions one
way or another in this one I was much
more interesting to produce this level
of distortion in a much more literal way
so then we did a whole series of kid
version for these Lambs
everyone's quite cute and then Jeff
Kipnis commissioned us to see we can do
like it literally in our piece made of
meat so we're trying to figure out how
to frost meat meal it and then combining
with some sort of metal things we did a
contraction Roy we did this mask for a
video for the rash band in Miami Alessi
asked again to Ribisi some ideas so we
came with this coffee cup
expresso cap which we just prototype
actually will work better for mati which
is not Cynthia infusion doesn't quite
work for espresso then you're gonna get
burned but we're working in how to make
it more precise we get commissioned by
JP Morgan investment bank in Los Angeles
to do a control remote control for them
so when I have meetings and they can
call their secretary to bring them
coffee and I had to say this is very
very tragic four days of work in this we
did like 20 for them we made more money
that two years working for Boeing it's
tragic because we call it is art and
banks have all these programs for our
investment whatever I don't want to get
that much in detail because it's a lot
of students in the audience and I don't
want to depress you and run and cross
the street and go to the art school but
it is a little bit like that anyway but
so this is the real one is built there
and they're happy and so on hopefully
they'll Commission more stuff so this
the flirtation with art became more and
more evident this is a commission that
we have right now for new galleries in
Miami want to sell in New York and in
London the Commission our work which is
believe me is way more difficult than
you think it is when they say oh can you
do a sculpture or not and I realized
okay I mean one would think it's over
for us but it's not so obvious because
there's not any specific problem to
fight with to me the notion the friction
that the enemy that you need to do a
procedure is crucial one is it when they
want is a work of art the thing is also
to me it created holes in their comfort
anyway we call this serious mercurial
chewing gum because it's what wolf
pricks call always called my project you
don't do architecture you mercurial
chewing gum so so these spheres of
pieces are calmer cooler chewing gum I
mean I don't it doesn't have any value
more than whatever and the flowers are
again so details to close up I think
it's another shift in paradigm I think
the idea of traditional tectonic detail
is moving into different one I think
people like Greg lien has been very very
smart about how to articulate this idea
I'm not so obsessed with those things
like Greg is as good and putting that
together neither but there is a whole
different notion of in which the
traditional Tektronix is moving into
different else and something much more
synthetic which I call it close ups
there's not so much anymore about the
detail of a synthetic thing I
technically is something much more
synthetic this was our entry for the
Helsinki National Library a couple of
years ago which operate a little bit
like that a little bit like that
the idea that it's accumulation of
clothes again it's not the building
doesn't do these things this is much
more a way to construct the film foreign
and this was one of the few times in my
life then I got really excited about a
competition result because they did a
public exhibition and we we were in the
we were in the top five chosen by the
people and I felt okay the jury maybe
Gideon's in the second phase then I
thought okay the people here we can sink
six months of nine six months of day
something wrong with him but that was
the first time I thought maybe we can do
it but no we didn't the jury didn't
respect the will of the people which I
feel very much like an urgent dynamic
assess what Argentinian precedence do so
in any case but this was well but what
were what to me was really important all
this project and the idea that we were
trying to work is he has a lot of
constrains one of them was basically you
had to fulfill the the block so it was
it was one of the first person and we
literally said okay let's work with the
box and let's start to break it down and
we'll go from there
so the strange thing was that what we
proposed was more than library with
purpose a winter park I mean we were
thinking whether it's very very brutal
so the idea was they who have multiple
name of park they library really happen
in the Faberge eggs and the part
happened there
so what you will think but all the
bookshelves runs through the park so the
idea was treated really the public
library would really are these days
which are public space and known anymore
libraries in the traditional sense and
to make it much more part of the part
and they have in front than they was to
make it a library some parallel to that
we were doing a lamp company it was a
very simple principle what if we get a
bunch of lamp bulbs and we melt it
together and then you can buy and you
can plug it in any lamp than you already
have we will see what happens they may
go to the production that family tree
got a very bad project than we did for a
competition in Taichung it's probably
one of the war thing we were done but
again it was this aside what to work
with in Canada familiarity what if we
were we were with a glass box or
recording wall and they think that the
storage goes down into the park how you
can read that through the plans how you
can navigate that and the idea that you
can have a kind of an on typological but
imagine more progressive sequency of
things the section is not the words but
this is really bad so the last two
projects I want to show you one is a
competition and we did for the National
Theatre in Bogota which again it goes
but much more in this kind of the
uncanny or the familiar of the most raw
city there is somehow relatable meaning
make it more or rific because part of
the problem was in this one we needed to
reconstitute the tissue of the city
so the really
kind of a courtyard and we start to
carve interior so in many way there is a
kind of a focus most trois City let's
say or not more like like it is it was
really not to butchery because we'd make
me make a literally feel at the block
and they will start to carve and
manipulate that carbon so the whole
process really happens in the quarry
which again is not that such an original
idea exams in a pretty much every
medieval city in Europe has but to me
was interesting because again it creates
this sort of a tension between the
recognized all familiar things that we
can relate to it and all these other
things they are the other possibilities
of the the species of the dismal the
cities of mutant form that come from
carrying that and the relation between
both of them I think I think it's
something that interests me very much
these days and we plan to keep working
on it so like everybody else in the
world
we did a going kind museum competition
for Helsinki Finland is another of our
what I call happy errors sorry supposed
to play bear with me okay let me replace
it
he always happens technology will always
let you down with projects where are you
here you are
OOP sorry I got the wrong person here at
the library
well that's one look we're gonna have
any luck
okay I guess of you that one for the
next time Danny mentioned no big deal
so but this is what we did and basically
it was one of your projects in a long
time that we were looking into a
proneness away to driven and basically
we're all alike that this was almost the
opposite of Guggenheim by Frank Gehry in
the sense of all the gallery space is
inside those strange shapes and
everything that is polygons whatever is
the most normative space we were trying
to reverse the logic I mean the idea to
produce which clearly is not a good
strategy since we didn't make it but
ideas to reverse some force a different
kind of negotiation between the notion
how they are the exhibition space will
work versus a public space so the idea
was at parking the public space will be
much more normative and exhibition space
will be less usual let's say for the
lego better world
those were the plans
and the last project is the one and I
show you the very first animation which
was the Budapest Museum and I think I
mean I like what we attempt to do in
moving on and what we did in this one
and I think that the next generation the
next up toxic project is gonna come out
of this - this one still was by the
accumulation of carbon and only carbon
pieces but the other one was to leave
the carcasses on the carbon how you can
negotiate the relation between both of
them and this one was I would say is way
more monomaniac and relentless in the
repetition of the features so right now
the work is trapped between these decode
these two these two ways to go around
and I'm very I'm very curious to see how
we're gonna start to negotiate these two
things and what is the number six Asian
contamination and we came to play which
is not clear to yet I mean we still are
in the butchery phase but it's moving
into something else that is not so
linear in relation to that so this
project to me is interesting in that
sense because it worked we kind of
relented accumulation so there is a
certain desire to produce even though it
may come through like that but the
desire to see if we can remove the power
of the singular form and have a
multiplicity of it and to see we can
remove the idea with object or singular
object in relation to automatic notion
with form but this is to be seen it's
not really so clear and apparent to me
what is gonna go fron it so I would like
to finish with a with a clip I always
used to finish this was a support I
really okay
trust everything's gonna be fine
you met me have a very strange time in
my life your plans trust me everything
is gonna be fine
but you should always tell your students
and your colleagues you Bend me I'm a
very strange time of my life thank you
very much
I trust you
I'm mercurial
your reliance which seems to maybe be
changing last project on the shiny
surface because for all the interest in
not just butchery but the grotesque and
the thing that keeps making it beautiful
and doesn't go into more dangerous
territory I think is is a shiny surface
which always always makes it beautiful
so yeah I'm wondering when you're gonna
give that up I don't think we want to
give it up anytime soon we try we try
many times to me that's the concession I
don't know I'm in the product the
product beauty always win in my internal
fight like my desires always let's see
how far we can go but then I always feel
like you need to come back somehow I
also think you have to do with my
incapacity I'm serious about this main
capacity the thing in terms of colors
and to do work with some of that
condition materially and also have to do
my own limitations to don't be so quick
on my feet when it comes to materials
and I think part of that is my fault but
part of that it's also too that we don't
get that many projects you really get to
that face that father for example the
project actually the I didn't show it to
you but the original version of the
bridge in Barcelona didn't have any
shiny thing it was all bamboo it was
four times more expensive there do any
metal so we have to back down from that
we try a couple of I mean we try here
and there I have a work it out and also
I think is one of the things I have in
common with fish I'm attracted to shiny
things there is something but I think
you go back to the notion of rituals I
think there's a fascination with the
shiny the refinement and goes Buddha so
I'm no I'm not ready to go all primitive
you know what I mean so but you're not
the first one who asked me and
encouraged being on the direction so
prolly get a shot though don't force him
to claim me yeah I tell you what worried
me the most when I no no I I have to say
when I saw the scale of where the bridge
was in this little pipsqueak canal and I
thought to myself when I had first seen
the bridge I thought it was crossing the
Aleutian straights or something and it's
really you know a teeny little backwater
canal and I think what about the
relationship of the scale and meaning of
a project to the energy of the forms
that you put in because it seems to me
that whether you're making a fork a
knife a glass pavilion a bridge a
building it's the same level of energy
yeah and to me I think that's a problem
what do you think well it is a problem
it is a problem to understand but I see
I I tried to ward that problem into
something that it can become it can
became a possibility to think about some
of those pressing in different ways so I
would say yes it's a pro in the way that
we traditionally and send out I don't
see so much as a problem because to me
actually if you tell me that that the
bridge looks way bigger than what it is
I think I think it as a compliment
because that's part of but is that's
part of the some of the thing what I was
talking about the scale is quality of
the world that interests me so I can
understand what you see as a problem and
I think you may have a fair point to it
but at the same time
Yeah right
and say which one is butchery I wouldn't
know how would one know I know
yeah but because you invented the term
but we don't need to appreciate what we
saw I love I love that you find that
puzzling when you were being the master
for the last 50 years combined in a war
that only you fully understand so I
learned from the best
joking aside No yeah what I want to say
is this when together butchery I'm not
saying that the whole work is a butcher
turn one instead is I see I use butchery
as a mechanism of contamination or
something is very in depth embedded in
their own nature of the software so the
work is hundred percent in better
embedded in the digital ideology for the
lack of word world so I think all these
things are efforts to try to see how
much we can take it out of that so it's
not that all the projects are butchery
and I think that there aren't all
different and by the way I don't think
they should not I mean I think it's ok
that we don't know which one is better
than the other one because I'm not
interested to work in those terms I'm
interesting to work in the projects have
that life and some of them they maybe
none of them are better than the others
and I'm ok with that
I mean so I think your criticism is fair
and you for sure have a point but at the
same time what I'm saying to you is part
of that criticism when I'm trying to
build as a possibility to work the work
through through that problem I think
there's another thing which are
practical aspect I mean sometimes you
project you develop projects but when
the projects are when you have a client
on the problem became a dancer you work
through it and you have time to water
some of these projects our competition
project and you work through processing
months months and half and they live and
die by those terms so some other thing
you're doing and you look at back here
and you horrify what am i drawn but it's
done
but and I think he served with a purpose
to get better later on so I don't know I
always like a lot of the notion of music
and albums and so on and some Oh some of
the one of my favorite musician which is
an argentinian guy called Gustav rowdy
who died last year in an interview he
says look I'm aware that some of my
songs are better than others
I'm aware than some people like Martin's
another now if you ask me I wrote every
thumb thing in Tosa hit so every person
then we do I think is the best thing
then we're done then you look at a note
and but at the same time I don't see it
in a way that this one is better than
the other one better than the other one
I don't war by multiplicity a war by IO
have a very clear sense where the person
want to be and the process is to get
there so I don't know I mean yeah hi
thanks for that if for a minute you
really mean it I don't have the feeling
when the students they relate to say
thank you for a great lake generally I
can be thinking so if you don't mean it
don't thank me
no question no I know I just asking do
you really lead it
I enjoyed the lecture thank you okay so
my question is my question is if for a
minute we were to assume that the
buildings that you were suggesting the
environments that you're suggesting are
not weird and if that's sort of the new
world that totality then the only thing
that really strikes me to be veered is
the sort of flat floors floor slabs the
wood decking just wondering if you would
get pissed off they come to my reviews
of my project you put floor yeah I
couldn't come up with a better idea to
work than a flat surface
what I mean by that is I think first of
all I really believe this I don't
believe that what I do is weird I mean I
I tried to give it the best answer I
give to a problem now I understand that
people can perceive it at that so to me
to have floors to have a section to have
a liberator stairs is what I do is what
I learn to do and I think is what part
of architecture does the architects are
admired they did that and they didn't
stop them for innovate and push the
boundaries so some of them better than
others true but I don't think and this
is something I had to work on it day I'm
still not quite there I don't think you
need to challenge every convention there
are certain things that like for example
none of my project challenged gravity I
don't want like that I mean that's one
in seven people as much as I love ladies
booth which I love him as a friend I
really don't like what people compare
what I do with live use because labia
made the conscious decision to don't
operate in the world of architecture
I haven't I mean now the world of
architecture and the client would know
one toe said me it's a different
discussion but I haven't made that
decision I'm interested in working when
I'm working and interested in doing them
and when we have a chance we development
and we try to build so I'm part of that
is to accept certain convention now
clearly I'm willing to say blessed
convention than other of my colleagues
and that's fine too but I don't know I
mean like you know it's a little bit
like your see the movie wedding crashers
at the very end there is and this guy
will Ferris crushing funerals and all
will system to the guy I hate funerals
man I don't want to judge you because
you're an innovator but I don't think
I'm ready for that so that's how we feel
our floor things and gravity I'm not
ready to go there
yeah I have a question I I never thought
about the earlier relationship you had
with Mariah's but I actually can see it
a little bit in the work and I'm curious
for I don't know how he produced his
drawings but there is the same
interested in repetitive cell a plane
that unites in a line that is ubiquitous
in affiliative to things around it that
is shared in the quality of your work
and I'm wondering with the software that
you're using that assigns materiality
very quickly whether that limits some of
the investigations you may be thinking
about in terms of materiality which you
said you haven't really thought about
yet but whether that's another way of
moving it from the abstraction say his
drawings to the hyper reality that's
already embedded into the software that
you're working with is that something
you've played off of conscious it hasn't
became that clear yet I mean part of I
don't know but the thing I was showing
animation with the cows and all that
that was kind of a poor man's attempt to
start to play with certain level of
dirtiness there was something I always
admire often rigged war was the capacity
he has also to work with this kind of I
mean all his buildings are very poorly
the old poorly built most of them until
the Scottish Parliament because they all
work in small towns at home but he would
totally embrace that level of the
earthiness and so on which is something
that they the computers take away from
it I mean there's a certain level of
dirtiness so all in a way all these are
efforts to see how much the art needs we
can bring into the computer even though
it's a very septic and I work a lot in
inside that contradiction I'm very aware
of the contradiction and it's part of
it's part of my own contradiction we
have to do with them and my fascination
with technology and super in a way I
think and I think this may be related to
what Peggy was asking and if you ask me
I realized what when you put all the
word together there in a way I could
argue that what I do it will be called
maximalism because it way there's a lot
of excess and lot of stuff but I never
never take off too became complete dirty
or whatever it's always pull back and
try to have some sort of elegance and
proportion that they're very
conventional so it's not like it's not
minimalism by any means but he has that
kind of idea to be in tune all the time
so and I think that's something by the
way that I think and reg was really good
at it I mean I mean to me or his world
was always in control
and despise what people think I think it
was incredibly precise so but ya know
it's a dirty mix it's pretty cool but I
don't know it's like many other things
in life right that he seems interested
in the Astra but they want you into the
dark and it's not that interesting all
right